plus d'enquêteurs pour traquer la
criminalité organisée plus de magistrats
et de greffiers pour une justice plus
efficace le Président annonce pour
novembre la création d'une CRS à l'image
de la crs8 donc une super CRS
spécialisée notamment dans les violences
urbaines ça fait deux ans que le plan
Marseille en grand est lancé pour
l'instant à Marseille en grand
banditisme le président ça fait 8 fois 8
fois depuis début de son mandat qui
vient il est à sa sixième année de
mandat et maintenant nous explique que
tout va changer tout va changer parce
qu'on est dans une séquence de com et
qu'il faut dire que tout va changer nous
promettez Marseille en grand comme j'ai
déjà dit on a eu que Marseille encens on
n'a pas eu de malheureusement
d'évolution en matière sécuritaire tous
les engagements pris il y a deux ans ont
été tenus
et cet historique je crains que ce soit
une énième accent de communication la
réalité de Marseille elle est personne
là c'est une délinquance une criminalité
qui ne cesse d'exploser et moi j'y
ajoute la responsabilité de toutes les
consommatrices et des consommateurs
c'est quand vous consommez vous
légitimez ces trafic le chef de l'État
annonce que les amendes pour
consommation de drogue pourront
désormais être payés immédiatement par
carte bancaire ou en liquide récupérer
l'argent en numéraire ou avant un
appareil à carte bleue pour le faire je
trouve que c'est une mission
supplémentaire qui n'est pas qui n'est
pas de de la compétence des policiers le
président de la République a fait le
constat que parfois ses amendes elles
mettaient beaucoup de temps à être
recouvré ou parfois elle ne l'était pas
et donc on doit pouvoir améliorer
l'effectivité des politiques publiques
je crois que c'est ça qui doit être
notre obsession parce que c'est ça
qu'attendre nos concitoyens la sécurité
est aujourd'hui l'angle mort d'Emmanuel
Macron et que en vérité en allant à
Marseille il va aussi d'accord je pense
aussi qu'en allant à Marseille il vient
constater son propre échec c'est de la
communication vous savez il y a
tellement de personnes ont dit qu'ils
allaient faire de bien à Marseille je
pense que les Marseillais
méritent de ne pas être considéré comme
des rats de laboratoire
je vais pas faire la course aux
commentaires des petites phrases
d'Emmanuel Macron parce que ça fait
objectivement 5 ans qu'on fait cela et
sur le fond il y a effectivement des
secteurs et je rencontre beaucoup moins
des chefs d'entreprise et
professionnelles de la restauration qui
sont des métiers dit en tension et qui
aujourd'hui ne trouvent pas de main
d'oeuvre on va tout de suite moi je vous
promets je fais le tour du lieu de porte
ce soir avec vous je vous trouve je suis
sûr qu'il y a 10h30
s'il semble être un sportif ordinaire
l'ex-corterback des commanders de
Washington Carson a partagé sur son
compte une toute autre passion les
clichés de sa partie de chasse ce
week-end tout sourire derrière la
dépouille de l'animal qu'il venait
d'abattre incroyable selon lui scruter
le ciel n'était pas l'activité numéro 1
ce matin à Brest
mais l'arrivée probable des fumées des
incendies Canadiens commencent à
inquiéter c'est dans un poste Instagram
que Marion Cotillard rapporte son
soutien en mouvement des soulèvements de
la terre publié ce dimanche l'actrice
française
oscarisée reprend le slogan du collectif
écologiste et se montrer critique
vis-à-vis du gouvernement
la liste des violences policières et de
ce fait gouvernemental contre les
mouvements écologistes donne le vertige
et la nausée les fumées engloutissent
Montréal qui battent aujourd'hui un
triste record celui de la ville la plus
polluée au monde
le masque est de retour dans les rues
les activités en extérieur sont
déconseillées plusieurs événements ont
été annulés elle regarde ça de loin dans
son existence 5 étoiles entre deux
tournages à Hollywood et une publicité
pour Chanel j'en ai assez de ces
personnalités qui s'achètent des brevets
de bonne conscience et qui vivent à
l'opposé de ce qu'elle dénonce voici
l'évolution du nuage en orange en fin de
journée il devrait toucher les codes
françaises le Royaume-Uni et continuer
vers l'Est cette semaine